sarah michel aulas bien une chose avec
les croquis ou par non non mais je
m'adresse à à ce qu'ils vont nous suivre
sont loin encore là ma carrière la
carrière et elle est faite et tout ce
qui se passe là penser que 48 ans
maintenant à savoir si c'est une grande
joie au milieu du guet chazellois 81 ans
donc je veux dire simplement aux jeunes
animateurs qui veulent essayer de
s'inscrire dans la durée
je vous réponds d'une formule excellente
qui est de marc tessier au concert
conférence de presse où il a dit la
thymine au service public doit être
insolente imprévisible
c'est le cas ici mais jamais à descendre
et qu'il ne faut jamais confondre la
télévision de proximité avec la
télévision de promiscuité
waouh je pourrais je pense à rien
merci michel merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup merci thierry à bientôt
je peux te poser une dernière question
minute quand est ce que tu écris tes
mémoires
bah écoute normalement ce pas sorti en
2005 ah voilà les toits qu'il va
balancer dans ses mémoires
je la diva de kilomètres les noms là non
je veux pas créer mémoire tout de suite
parce que comme dirait thierry j'ai peur
que ça sent le sapin
c'est bien
savons nous
car le derrière